Our beaches have always been popular for fishing and white baiting
and it makes life easier if you can drive your equipment out to your favourite spot.
Under the Northern Pegasus Beach Bylaw that’s still fine
but there are some rules around vehicles you need to be aware of.
You can only drive on the beach for approved purposes.
That includes launching a boat, or transporting equipment for fishing, white baiting or Mahinga Kai.
Here at Kairaki, if you hold a mobility parking permit
you can also bring your car onto the beach.
But recreational driving, or driving just for pleasure is not allowed
and neither are two-wheeled motorbikes.
You also need to stick to the designated areas
which are from the Waimakariri River Mouth to the red post located 2.5km north of The Pines Beach
and from north of the Ashley Rakahuri Estuary up to the Hurunui District boundary.
When driving, stay below the last high-tide mark,
and give way to people and animals at all times.
You should be going no faster than 30km/h
and slowing right down to 10km/h when within 50 meters of people.
So it’s not difficult. Keep to the designated areas
for the approved purposes and drive safely.
We’ve all got a part to play in preserving our beaches & estuary.